bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociaux logos alors quand on est
végétarien végétalien vegan bref quand
on ne mange pas de chair animale de
produits animaux on entend souvent des
critiques qui sont que le fait d'être
végétarien vegan etc
c'est un truc de privilégier un truc de
bobos
un truc de blanc est aujourd'hui dans
cette vidéo je voulais revenir un peu
sur ses affirmations et montré qu'elles
ne sont pas si vrai que ce qu'on
voudrait nous faire croire déjà dans un
premier temps la critique qui est de
dire que le fait d'être végétarien c'est
un privilège c'est quelque chose qu'on
entend beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment dans les milieux militants
quand on fait ce qu'on appelle le
tchèque et privilèges donc c'est le fait
de présenter un petit peu les privilèges
dont bénéficient par exemple le fait
d'être blanc le fait d'être un homme
le fait d'être hétérosexuel et c est
donc parmi ceux là certains disent que
fait d'être végétarien l'aide légale
c'est un privilège en fait le privilège
tel qu'il est décrit dans ces milieux là
ça a pour but de montrer linverse d'une
discrimination par exemple je suis
discriminés en tant que femme mais je ne
suis pas discriminer puisque je suis
blanche et de manière plus nuancée et
plus précise on va dire qu en sociologie
être privilégiée c'est de se trouver du
côté dominant d'un rapport de pouvoir
en fait en sociologie on étudie les
relations sociales comme toujours une
relation de force une région une
relation de pouvoir et être privilégiée
c'est bénéficier de cette relation qui
se fonde sur l'oppression d'un autre
groupe de personnes
par exemple on va dire que les hommes
bénéficient de manière générale du
rapport de force envers les femmes dans
la société patriarcale
tout comme les chefs d'entreprise les
grands dirigeants bénéficient du rapport
de forces qui les oppose aux classes
populaires ouvrière salariés de même que
les personnes blanches bénéficie d'une
histoire qui est fondée sur le racisme
l'esclavagisme etc et donc sont
privilégiées par rapport aux personnes
noires ou précisé mais si on suit cette
logique du privilège ça veut dire que
quand on accuse un végétarien un régal
d'être un privilégié
on sous-entend qu'il bénéficie d'un
rapport de force mais du coup par
rapport à qu en fait là où c'est
vraiment une fausse idée
et c'est que au contraire les
végétariens les végétaliens les vegan
ils font ses choix alimentaires pour
combattre un rapport de force qui existe
déjà et qui voit des êtres humains aux
animaux c'est à dire ils refusent
l'exploitation par les humains des
animaux
en fait ces personnages objets tariel
vegan végétalien refusent de s'inscrire
dans un rapport de pouvoir et surtout au
delà de refuser de chercher et lui
refuse d'en bénéficier refuse refuse
d'en tirer un bénéfice personnel ou même
en tant que groupe
en fait en refusant de s'inscrire dans
ce rapport de force les végétariens et
vegan remettent en cause l'un des
rapports de domination fondamentale de
notre société et c'est aussi pour ça que
les attaques alors garçon extrêmement
virulente
alors que ben a clairement au niveau
individuel ça reste juste des personnes
qui mangent des légumes et des pois
chiches pour congo donc voilà pour ce
premier rapport de force qui est l'idée
que pour être l'égérie faut être
privilégiée ou que edge arrivée j au
contraire c'est une manière de remettre
en cause un système qui nous fait prix
être privilégié quand on mange de la
viande et des produits laitiers
alors la deuxième attaque pendant un
très souvent par rapport aux végétariens
et notamment encore plus je dirais aux
vagal c'est le fait que ce soit soit
disant un truc de bobos
alors pour en revenir à la base du
problème le fait d'être bobo donc c'est
d'être bourgeois bohème et personnes
qu'on va cacher de bobo c'est une
personne qui a un capital économique et
culturel élevé c'est-à-dire une personne
qui est très aisé financièrement et qui
dans le même temps bénéficie de par son
éducation sa famille d'un capital
culturel élevé c'est-à-dire de
prédisposition à la compréhension de la
manière dont s'est organisé la société a
un accès plus élevé est plus aisé
surtout à la culture etc
alors dire que le fait d'être
végétarienne en mégane truc de bobos
ça revient du coup dans un premier temps
à dire que pour être végétarien on veut
gagner il faut être aisée financièrement
et ça selon moi c'est totalement une
idée reçue
alors pourquoi déjà dans le monde de
très nombreuses personnes vivent avec
une alimentation végétarienne ou vegan
donc en ce cas à base de produits
végétaux non animaux est en fait ces
personnes elles suivent un régime
alimentaire végétalien tout simplement
la viande le poisson les
the les produits laitiers sont des
produits des denrées alimentaires qui
sont extrêmement chères quand on compare
le prix d'un légume local versus de la
viande un kilo de viande vers 600 kg
d'oignons ou que sais-je
il n'y a pas photo tout simplement donc
ce sont des produits qui sont
excessivement chers qui ne sont tout
simplement pas accessible pour toutes
les bourses
donc là on a vraiment une inversion de
la logique qui veut que quand même
pouvoir manger de la viande à tous les
repas
ça reste quelque chose qui n'est pas
accessible à des gens qui sont dans des
situations financières modèle c'est un
manga très précis actuellement j'habite
en turquie clairement ça me coûte moins
cher d'acheter des légumes des pois
chiches des lentilles etc à de très
rares exceptions il revient quand même
toujours plus cher à une famille
d'investir dans de la viande ou du
poisson au quotidien par contre là où il
ya une forme de vérité selon moi dans le
fait de dire que les végétariens vegan
son bobo c'est pour la partie plutôt
capitale culturelle en fait ici ce qui
me fait dire qu'il ya une part de vérité
c'est que pour ceux réclamés soit même
du végétarisme du véganisme pour
déclarer je suis végétarien pour
s'inscrire dans tout le côté mouvement
politique il ya autour du véganisme
c'est quelque chose qui demande fait
d'avoir accès à des personnes qui ont
elles mêmes ce mode de vie des personnes
qui ont déjà assumé pris leur place en
tant que végétariens ou en tant que
végal en fait à partir du moment où on
veut on peut remettre en cause quelque
chose qui est considéré comme
déterminant dans la société et en plus
qui a une implication culturel très
fortes à dire l'accès à la nourriture
eh bien vous robuste venir se
revendiquer d'un mouvement politique
comme ça il faut avoir accès est tout
simplement à une certaine littérature
sur le sujet à des écrits à la
compréhension de rapports de pouvoir etc
c'est pas juste vivre son alimentation
dans son coin c'est mettre un mot dessus
qui a une dimension politique est
forcément ceux ci demandent un capital
culturel plus élevé donc au sujet des
jardins mégane qui seraient des bobos
si le fait d'avoir une alimentation
végétale ne ressort en rien d'un
privilège et notamment d'un petit
village économique
le fait de voir se définir comme tels
revient quand même de manière
disproportionnée
chez des personnes qui ont un capital
culturel elle
et le troisième point que je voulais
aborder c'est quelque chose que j'ai
commencé à entendre vérité il ya
quelques mois je vois là c'est le fait
de dire que le végétarisme avait gagné
c'est un truc de blanc c'est un problème
de blanc alors pourquoi ça me pose un
grand souci d'entendre ça c'est que tout
simplement le végétarisme le véganisme
n'est pas du tout l'apanage des
personnes blanches c'est-à-dire des
personnes encore aux européennes
occidentales encore je pense que là où
il ya confusion c'est sur la manière de
se présenter et de dire je suis
végétarien je suis légal en effet ces
deux mots soient arrivés assez
tardivement tout simplement
c'est quelque chose d'assez récent est
en effet les mots végétarien vegan très
présente dans la culture occidentale
pour autant la grande majorité de la
population végétarienne a su elle est
tout simplement en inde dont les
personnes qui sont pas blanches déjà
pour commencer
donc il ya toute une partie de la
population indienne et que partiellement
hindous qui ne consomment pas de
produits animaux et ces personnes sont
végétariennes et c'est pas du tout
quelque chose de subissez pas pour des
raisons économiques c'est vraiment
quelque chose de culturel qui est ancrée
et qu'on voit dans la religion etc
on ne mange pas les animaux ensuite je
pense que tout ce qu'il faut un peu
déconstruisent comme idc idée que le
végétarisme l'avait gagné c'est quelque
chose de nouveau c'est un peu comme une
mode occidentale des problèmes de blancs
que sèche qu'on entend un peu dans le
milieu le militant sur les réseaux
sociaux
selon moi c'est faux puisque en fait
quand on se penche un petit peu sur
l'alimentation traditionnelle les repas
typique de très nombreux peuples dans le
monde entier de l'amérique latine à
l'asie en passant par l'afrique
subsaharienne jusqu au moyen-orient'
bref il ya quand même une grande
majorité de peuples qui vivent et qui
ont longtemps vécu avec une limite une
alimentation qui n'est pas animal quand
on étudie la scène typique de différents
peuples dans la période pré-industrielle
ce qu'on remarque c'est que la
consommation de viande ou de poisson est
quand même assez rare à l'exception
évidemment des les peuples côtiers et
c'est en fait on a plus tôt
acs qui est composé de fruits avec frais
de légumineuses de céréales de féculents
voilà des choses qui sont donc végétal
qui pousse qui sont issus de
l'agriculture et non de l'élevage
mais surtout pourquoi il y a eu que très
peu de viande et de poisson dans les
assiettes de nos ancêtres
c'est tout simplement puisque il était
bien plus facile est bien plus simple en
terme de logistique aussi de s'occuper
de terre dans lequel on fait pousser du
blé de l'orge et c'était un de récolter
ce que la nature produit par elle-même
dans le cycle de fonctionnement de la
nature plutôt que de tuer un animal
clairement un animal qu'on a en élevage
il apporte beaucoup plus à l'homme en
étant vivent plutôt qu'une fois qu'il
est mort dans l'assiette c'est quand
même des années et les années pour
élever par exemple un cochon et au final
je veux tuer le manger en quelques jours
donc voilà je pense qu est ce que vous
avez pensé c'est une une vision qu'on a
eus qui s'est un peu décalée du feq de
maintenant avoir un élevage industriel
qui permette de donner cette impression
qu'on peut toujours produire de la
viande en continuité alors qu'en fait ça
mais des années pour élever un animal le
faire grandir qui se développe et c'est
donc voilà cette vidéo pour vous dire
que j'ai un peu du mal à entendre ce
genre de critiques sur le fait qu être
végétarien vegan c'est être privilégiée
c'est être un bobo ou encore c'est
quelque chose que seulement les blancs
peuvent faire puisque c'est faux et je
vous invite à consulter les autres
ressources que je vous mettrais anvar
d'information il ya des choses très
intéressantes à apprendre sur le sujet
j'ai été assez rapide dans cette vidéo
donc n'hésitez pas si vous voulez aller
plus loin j'espère que cette vidéo vous
a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à ma chaîne rejoindre sur
instagram et puis je me retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo sur sociaux logos
[Musique]